in this question we are going to graph
some familiar shapes
that have been dressed up in very
unfamiliar clothes and they also have
some
some weird catches some weird curveballs
kind of built into them so
let's have a look at this question and
see what sense we can make of it
sketch the graph of the set of points z
for which
z minus 1 on z minus i this fraction
here whatever that's equal to
for which that is real or imaginary
we're going to get two different graphs
here
at these two different questions so how
do i tackle this well the first thing
that immediately jumps out at me
is that the two parts of this question
part a asking for it to be real
and part b asking for it to be imaginary
what they suggest to me is that i'm
going to need to think about this
complex number
z and the result that you get from z
minus one on z minus i
i'm going to think of this in cartesian
form and that's because you know i've
got three forms
that i i generally um have at my
disposal and i
kind of have to interpret off of the
question which might be the most useful
form and sometimes it doesn't matter
really which one you use
but sometimes it really does matter
right if for example you have a question
and it's saying to you something to do
with angles and there's multiplication
and division that's kind of a bit of a
hint for you especially if they're
talking about
arguments in a specific way maybe i
should be in polar form because
the theta is right there in the cos
theta plus i sine theta
with an r out the front for whatever
modulus you choose if you on the other
hand
see complex numbers being raised to
powers where you see exponentiation
that kind of indicates to you well maybe
exponential form might be the most
useful or demarvous theorem so you kind
of got a 50 50 there you could use polar
form as well
now when you have a look at the way this
question is written i wonder if you can
tell what's the thing that nudges me
toward
using cartesian form or rectangular form
and that is that
this part of the question here and here
requires the real and the imaginary
components to be separated out
very neatly from each other and you can
see for example
when we take the uh exponential form of
a complex number
it's a single thing r e to the i theta
which part of this is the real part and
which part is the imaginary part
the answer is it's kind of all
intertwined right you can more easily
separate it in
polar form but you might as well go to
the form that very cleanly distinguishes
between here's the real part
here's the imaginary part and that is
cartesian form that does the best job
not only that but in terms of sketching
a graph we are used to we have all this
knowledge built up over years
about how um to graph cartesian
equations and so we might as well kind
of use all that knowledge to help us
solve this question so with that in mind
what i'm going to do is i'm going to say
well let's
take this complex number z and express
it in cartesian form so i'm just going
to say it's
x plus i y now if that is the case then
i can rewrite the question that's been
provided
to me this fraction here i can rewrite
it in terms of this x plus iy stuff
and that will help me form a bridge to
getting
parts a and b so therefore z minus 1
on z minus i is going to be equal to
just going to do a straight substitution
first
it's x plus i y minus 1 and then
x plus i y minus i
now the whole point in choosing
cartesian form is so that i can
cleanly separate out the real and the
imaginary components but
this complex number here whatever this
whole thing is equal to
um you can see the components are not
neatly separated they're kind of mixed
together
in the numerator and the denominator and
intertwined so in order to
sort of separate them out more cleanly
what i need to do is go back to the very
beginning of the course
something we've been doing for a long
time here which is to multiply this
fraction
by the conjugate of the denominator
because then i can use difference of
squares
i can realize the denominator and then i
can start separating things out so let's
have a go at that
what is the conjugate of x plus iy
minus i well in fact before i multiply
it might be
better or more helpful to me if i start
to
begin this process of separating out
real and imaginary so on the numerator
i've got x minus 1
that's real and then i've got i y that's
imaginary
and then on the denominator that is a
really
wonky line there i'm going to have my x
that's the only real component
and then everything that has an i
attached to it is going to be the
imaginary component and you can see if i
factorize that out
i get y minus 1. now this makes it much
easier for me to identify what the
conjugate should be
because when you take this term here
all you need to do is take that plus i
y minus 1 and turn it into a minus
i y minus 1. so that is the conjugate it
goes up the top and the bottom so that
you're not actually changing the
fraction and now what i'm going to do is
i'm going to multiply through and
hopefully if i've done this right
i will be able to get a real denominator
and then i can separate my real and
imaginary components on the numerator
all right let's have a go so on the top
here i'm going to have
i'm going to do x minus 1 multiplied by
each of these terms first so what do i
get
i'm going to have x x minus 1 and then
i'm going to get
minus i x minus 1 y
minus 1. so i hope you can see that's
come from me
combining x minus 1 with this final term
over here just watch out for the sign
and the i that's hanging around so far
so good
let me now distribute this i y across to
these other terms so that gives me in
the first instance
plus i x y
and then be careful here i've got a
minus but then i have an i
squared there's one i here and then
there's another i
there and then that leaves me with y
y minus 1. so there's nice symmetry with
some of those earlier terms as well
okay let's draw a nice big fraction line
and what's happening on the denominator
well
it's this difference of squares things
we were talking about for right so i've
got x squared
and then i subtract i squared y
minus 1 squared and that's it that's
already been factorized according to
difference of squares
all right can we tidy this up a little
bit we certainly can so i notice that
there's
a real number there this is going to
become a real number once i deal with
the minus i
squared and then what you've got left in
the middle here as we so often see
is the imaginary component because you
can see the eye can factorize out in
both cases
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
separate them out
i get that x x minus 1 that's out the
front
and then this becomes minus i squared is
plus 1.
so that will be plus y y minus 1.
that looks good and then as i move
across
to the right you can see i'm going to
factorize out i and that leaves me with
let's have a look what's inside the
brackets
i've got x y take away
x minus 1 y minus 1.
there we go have a look did i do that
right so i've just popped this term out
the front because it's positive
and then this term with the minus sign
comes into the back here
and then on the denominator you can see
i can also tidy that up just a little
bit i can do that same
minus i squared cancellation so that
just gives me plus
y minus 1 all squared okay so
that's looking good i can go a little
bit further than that though because
this is still a bit of a complicated
mess
what i can do for instance is i can say
well
on the left hand side i can actually
expand this all out right i get x
squared minus x plus y
squared minus y and then while i'm at it
i might as well
separate this out as its own fraction
because this is all the real components
there are no more imaginary bits
so the denominator comes along for the
right x squared
plus y minus 1 squared as we saw in the
previous line and then what do i get
here well
i add i'm going to factorize out the i
what do i get on the numerator
let's look at this carefully so i've got
the xy hanging out the front there
and then i'm going to subtract now i've
got to expand this pair of binomials so
it looks to me like i get x
y minus x minus y
plus 1. and that
that is all divided by the same
denominator
that i saw before so draw that fraction
there
x squared plus y minus 1 or squared
okay i'm almost there this is me you
know taking
taking this and
i've got the real component i'm happy
with how that's been
simplified and then over here with the
imaginary component
you can see that my xy's i'll use purple
my xy's are going to cancel
and that just leaves the rest of these
terms but you've got to watch out for
that negative sign that's going to
distribute to everything in there
so let's go ahead and write that out x
y's are gone that leaves me with
x plus y minus 1.
and that is going to be divided by the
same denominator that we saw
earlier x squared plus y minus 1
all squared okay happy times now
i've got the all this working was just
so that i could separate out
the real part from the imaginary part
because remember if something is going
to be real
then the condition for that is that i'll
use the same colors
the imaginary part here is going to have
to be
0 right in fact it's not the imaginary
part of z it's actually the imaginary
part of this whole awkward fraction here
right so it's actually going to be
z minus 1 on z minus i
if if that imaginary component there is
0
then i should get a real number by the
same token but using the opposite logic
if my
real component of z minus 1 on z
minus i if that real component is 0 then
in theory that should only leave
an imaginary part so this is going to be
my framework my pathway
into solving part a and part b but as
you're about to see
you still need to be careful so let's
start to write our working
right